let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud and
do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
so
who we're talking about here hello
welcome back to episode three
today is a very special episode because
today is the first time
we have had a guest on this podcast
which i am very excited about
and i am very excited about who that
guest is
and i'll be introducing him soon but i
want to talk about a few things
and sorry for the delay in the video
we're having a little bit of delay but
we'll work through that the audio will
be fine
but i want to talk about a few things
here that have had popped up in the last
few days and i and i know we're going to
get our guest opinion on
uh specifically this these issues
but we've seen a lot more video of
marjorie taylor green and how some of
this q anon
stuff has leaked into congress a lot of
people think that this is
a bad thing that marjorie taylor greene
won a congressional seat that marjorie
taylor green
is displaying her crazy
all over washington i don't think it's a
bad thing i really don't
i think this is a great thing i think
this is
the way that the gop
has to handle it what i mean is
what are you gonna do with these nut
bags now now that now that you guys have
grown your
garden of wackadoos and now you wanna
you wanted to harvest them on january
6th now that you've harvested them
are you going to make a sandwich out of
them are you going to make a soup out of
them
you know what are we going to do with
these with these loons that you got now
and who's going to deal with them who's
gonna deal with them
is it gonna be you is it gonna be your
party that purges these people from your
party
oh this is gonna be fantastic folks this
is gonna be great entertainment and we
have
we have evidence of this in the past in
recent past i've talked about it before
uh mr stephen king of iowa
where mr stephen king was purged from
the party for being an
outright racist now this q a on stuff
you know is a thin veil of white
privilege and white supremacy
uh and it's all it's all it's all
badged up and it's got a name tag on it
that kind of looks like white
evangelical christians and we're going
to talk about that today and we're going
to break that down more with our guest
but it does have this gross feeling to
it
but we've seen this before where they
handicap a congress
person like they did steve king and
steve king lost his
primary of course and then that new
uh racist republican in iowa
became the congressman just just not so
overtly racist
like steve king you know give it another
thin veil
would you please so but let's get to
who our guest is today because i really
want to get into talking to him about
this these type of subjects
because he's done uh several videos
on trump supporters he's done several
music videos on
trump supporters which everyone loves
everyone loves him playing into guitar
and singing into tick tock
and giving us the the uh what is tick
tock tick tock calls it
the hate speech on trump supporters
they take his videos down because it's
hate speech he calls them trump
supporters
uh you know we call them trump
supporters and we get
we get uh taken down off tick tock for
hate speech for calling them trump
support i don't understand that but
we'll probably get into that a little
bit but um uh
our guest today is michael j at one
black man's opinion uh that's his page
on tick tock
everyone knows uh that he
really likes to go after the trump
supporters which is what i like about
him the most
that he really really really takes that
hot poker and really digs it in nice and
deep
where it counts too really where it
counts
and then and then you add in you add in
the fact
that this guy can strum on a guitar and
sing a tune on top of that
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] talk about a christmas
gift
so i want to play you one of his videos
and then we'll we'll
bring him on so you guys can hear a
little bit from him
uh this is one of his popular videos and
i believe that this is one of my
favorite that he's done
and i believe it's been taken down
before uh for for trump hate speech
and then and then they he appealed and
of course they brought it back up
because it's not [ __ ] hate speech
it's just
their [ __ ] snowflakes is the problem
so let's play this video here
[Music]
donald trump tonight
so if you're not following one black
man's opinion on tick tock get your ass
over there and follow him i'm not right
now go over after the podcast
obviously stay here and watch him you
know tell us what his opinion of this is
but i'm going to bring i'm going to
bring michael jay in how are you buddy
how are you hello i'm good brother i'm
telling you what you about to get fired
as my new press agent because that was
thank you thank you you're welcome
you're welcome hey i know a lot of
people
a lot of people like your page and they
like your content over there
it's very obvious and you know what's
the best part the best part to me is
there's a lot of people that hate your
content a lot of people oh god
and it's and it's the best kind of
people that hate your content so
you know you're doing something right
over there when they ban
that video for hate speech because you
said trump got banned from
twitter i i i think the fact that that
the only
it's it's it's kind of it's it's the
pettiest of the petty i mean it's
tom petty it's rich it's richard petty
bro
it's jay paul getty teddy it's it's it's
it's the fact that all you can do now
since your great leader let you down
let me just go in here and just screw
with other people because it's literally
all i have left
so it's it at some point you kind of
hope to grow up and move past it but
i mean you know with this conspiracy
theory [ __ ] that we're going to talk
about here with q anon and marjory
taylor green and right
um some of the some of this craziness
that we have going on in the country
right now
and still perpetuating you know it's
kind of like you know jfk
and some of the uh some of the
conspiracy theories around jfk
assassination i mean these people still
believe some of that craziness
well you know something it's a
conspiracy theory is a lot easier to
deal with
than than than just dealing with the
possibility that there's just some
really [ __ ] up [ __ ] in the world
so it's it's it's easier for people to
to hold on to this
like the magic bullet theory i'm just
like how do you even
roll with that with a straight face it's
just like
okay i you know and and
you know i've seen the the brooder film
i've watched the unedited version of it
and
and you know i i see stuff like when you
know secret service gets
waved off the car i'm like i'm sorry let
me get this straight you're gonna let
the president of the united states
roll down the street with no protection
whatsoever the the the it
it it amazes me though that the [ __ ]
that people will hold on to
out of fear and and that and that's
pretty much what it is
but do you think do you think that's
where this q a cuz i i truly believe
that
that this q anon stuff really didn't
start as white supremacy or
or white grievance but it you know these
professional white supremacists and
we've talked about this before the other
day when we were doing some technical
testing here
that that these these are professional
white supremacists these people
make a living perpetuating this [ __ ]
yes they do and
and i think they caught on to this q
anon stuff
that hey this is a good way to get
people to believe our
ideas with this veil of the internet and
this veil of of
this anonymous being called the queue
right um to really perpetuate their
ideas and start this
to grow this garden of white grievance
and the and the thing is like you're
saying
where uh people want they want
the unknown explained by something
that's easy to understand
right i think that's where a lot of
these white evangelical christians have
really taken a hold of this q anon stuff
and it's really kind of bled into
what their groups are about and uh you
know you it starts to
it starts to sound with people standing
on the outside
a little bit like craziness and these
people are in a nut house
um but don't you think that it has a lot
to do
with mental mental health care and the
mental state of some people in this
country
i think and the fact that that that most
of these people seem to reside in red
states
i think says a lot it it it in most of
those states
are in some ways they perform subsidy
it's it's
you know it's in and these are the
people who for some type of reason
feel so superior to come online and tell
you
how the world works it's like i'm like
if you live in kentucky bro
shut up seriously just stop
talking okay it's you're you're like in
one of the poorest states in the union
you need to be worried about other stuff
then then dudes marrying other dudes
that is the least of your worries at
this point in the game
so but you know it's
i i i try to understand it all the time
but i i
i think that at some point we're going
to have to take accountants
for the the lack of mental health
in this country the lack of mental
health preparedness
a lot of law enforcement has absolutely
no idea what to do
with a a person who is you know has
has emotional issues or an autistic
person
because i personally have two autistic
children now if something happens to my
children
by police
i'm going i'm gonna be a james bond
villain man
well you know you know but but we get we
get all these issues we get mental
health care we get white privilege we
get this white supremacy
we get this oh we're being oppressed
because there's equality we get this all
mixed into this pot
and we have this this this this
blatantly obvious problem
with a certain percentage of the
population and i find it amazing that
for so many people
equality is oppression i find that
amazing
that there's so many people that
actually believe that for a group of
people that have equal rights somehow
they're losing theirs and this concept
of
their they're taking america from us
nobody's taking
america from you nobody's trying to take
your guns you all been saying that [ __ ]
for years they're coming for our guns
nobody's trying to take your guns i
don't believe there's a politician in
this country
crazy enough to to even propose
taking your guns y'all gonna have to
screw up on a major level for that kind
of crap to happen
but the simple truth of the matter is is
is
people get it's just
we can i i i you know it's like tangent
you know right right well there's so
much and that's and that's the thing
so let me play a video that i did back
in um
in mid december i did this tick tock
okay because my
because my gears were turning back in
about this q and on stuff
and watching people like marjory taylor
green this bobert
um tommy tuberville some of these people
that we're gonna talk about here in a
minute
um it really it really did start to
i thought this is a this is not just
this
this serious white supremacy these
people are believing this stuff
because not only have they been bred to
believe this stuff
but they had this mental illness not to
capture facts not to have their radar on
for facts so let me play that video real
quick so let's talk about our mental
health state oh
[ __ ] have you seen this website parlor
holy nut bags batman it's where the
wackadoos
do what wackadoos do we've let mental
health slip so [ __ ]
far in this goddamn country that this is
the closest thing that we have to an
insane asylum
considered an online internet nut house
even making a movie call it uh
one flew over the orangutan's nest to
think
that the only people in this country
with [ __ ] brains that voted against
this stupid bastard
are the ones fighting for these people
to actually get some [ __ ] mental
health care
jesus [ __ ] it no these people are
against universal health care
but we really need to get them fistfuls
of head drugs
stat we could slip it in their trump
kool-aid in the morning
piece of advice for you morons next time
you pick a leader
try not picking a loony that kind of
[ __ ] runs downhill
[ __ ] them
so so i don't by the way this is one of
the reasons why i watched this man that
[ __ ] you just saw right there
which is now like 10 times more intense
okay
right yes yes it is i've gotten more and
more intense because
i i figured out something uh very
quickly with these walking videos and i
don't know what it is about me walking
because literally i just
i go for my daily walk and i started to
do these videos and i think it was about
the time
that the stimulus package this debate
started going on and i really got pissed
off about that
because i seen all this gaslighting and
all this [ __ ] about this two
thousand dollar check
and all these [ __ ] just
completely lying to
to their base and the trump the trump
base going yeah we need two thousand
dollars
like you you mean socialism you mean
like that
you [ __ ] idiots the [ __ ] that you
railed about for
months and months how it's going to
destroy our country that's the [ __ ] you
want
so um i guess so i started to really
uh uh get a little extra on it right and
and i like the extra and everyone likes
the extra so i take it to the extra mile
but yeah it's perfect too man i love it
i i appreciate that i appreciate that
but
but as far as the mental health in this
country um you know
it really it really is uh a good thing i
think though that we're pointing this
out to these people because i
i think they're finally realizing some
of them
they're realizing holy [ __ ] we were
duped like i did a i did a video about
the q
shaman this you know the buffalo yeah
yeah the buffalo dude yeah yeah yeah
about how he he feels he was duped
i'm like oh my god you feel i'm sorry
[ __ ] your feelings you're right right
i i said in the i said in the video i
said that's your radar picking up facts
and that's the thing it's like
you [ __ ] changing your mind and
how you feel about all this stuff
this is just more evidence more evidence
that you either knew the facts and
ignored them
or now you're realizing that you were
[ __ ]
dead wrong about the entire thing that's
the whole thing
and and and that drives me crazy because
i literally like four
[ __ ] years we told you all
he wasn't worth a [ __ ] four years we
literally said donald trump is a lions
sack of crap
we literally said this to you and
instead of listening for
donald trump integrated president obama
okay do you see where we are right now
where we are right now is under donald
trump's leadership where we are
right now i literally have somebody the
other day trying to post it to post a
video talking about
well 4 000 more people died under joe
biden's watch i'm sorry did you forget
about the other
400 000 that died
under your boy's watch the ability for
trump supporters to pretend like
nothing is wrong on their side of the
fence
has never ceased to amaze me these
people consistently
are like not us no no that's the it's
the [ __ ] liberals
no no no the only reason trump isn't
getting done anything done
because of the liberals they tried that
[ __ ] the first two years when they were
in complete control
well the liberals you all are running
every [ __ ] thing
how is it the liberals well what's crazy
they've been doing this
last 30 years you know it's the brown
people coming from mexico
and then oh well if if we could just
clean up the ghettos or
what you know it's on and on and on and
on with this [ __ ]
blaming blaming blaming everybody but
themselves
well you know you you know how black
people are you know well you know yeah
well we're pro i'm sure well i'm sure
we're gonna get into that
with one black man hey i got a surprise
for you though speaking of trump
supporters
i got a surprise so so you had a video
you had a video that was taken down
and i may have i may have done something
here so let
they wear me hats you can see
[Music]
they'll believe in a stupid story
that's coming from the gop they call
them trump supporters
[Music]
[Music]
don't worry that you're sitting in a
jail cell
i'm sure
[Music]
[ __ ] stupid supporters
you are my boy forever dude so i catch
you
so i captured that before they deleted
it now if anyone doesn't know that video
um and hopefully you get your appeal but
uh if not i'll i'll send you a copy and
uh so you can repost it because oh
definitely cuz [ __ ] em
but uh [ __ ] em but here's the thing is
is
so i captured that video because i
thought may i might need a couple more
videos of him singing songs and i really
like that one
so i captured that one and i'm so glad
that i captured that one because it got
taken down so now it will live on
youtube
so for everyone to see so we can promote
it through
youtube even if they keep it down off
tick tock so tell us about that video
tell us what what what inspired it and
then what happened the story behind it
not being on tick tock
um the amazing thing
about that video is is is is
you know i i i i confess
lyrically it's one of my favorites
because i i i i try to be as as i try to
stick as close to the the rhythm of the
original song as possible
i think that helps sell it and um
it it i get inspired like i get inspired
for a lot of the parodies i do i don't
i basically just sit around and play and
i'll be thinking about trump supporters
or some stuff like that
and in the lyrics will just come the the
one that i just did
the ones i literally just did use an
outcast
that hit me this morning that literally
hit me this morning so
yeah and i was i was watching that one
and
so when i watched that when i was
actually putting together this last clip
um and i was like ah should i do three
and i so i grabbed two of them
i grabbed the one you know for a
surprise to give you uh
to give you your video back um thank you
yes absolutely so it'll always live on
here you have to fast forward
unless tick tock gives you your appeal
and or if you repost it and they let you
keep it up
and and let me say something about about
um
you know i i'm just i i i find that the
the creative process itself
is just again it's one of those things
where
i'll just be sitting and just you know
[ __ ] around
just playing something i'll be playing a
song and just start you start singing
something crazy
and then also you go
you know i i love the lyrics of that one
but there's one word in there that i
really
i really wish you would have played off
of and that's insurrection
because we watched chuck schumer on the
senate floor this week
call it an erection and i was like oh
oh insurrection erection oh my god so if
you could do us
a song that has
those those words in it that would be
fanta i'm just
i'm now i'm just throwing out you know
about questions
yeah requests
so so let's talk about speaking of
erections
let's talk about um uh mr mr
giuliani uh and how he's been in the
news here
lately i could put my arms around that
man jump up and down and jack him off
that's how big of a dick he is seriously
that's
that's that's you know what it was i i
i really so this story about
um this the insurrection in january 60's
i don't
i don't think we're anywhere close to
this this story being gone
oh god no oh god and i i don't think
they've even tapped
uh even a tip of the iceberg here of who
was involved and
and the big names that were involved
because we were seeing pictures and
stories now
that not only was uh trump's lawyer rudy
giuliani
but uh his family eric and don
apparently i think kimberly guilfoyle
was at this meeting at the trump
at the trump dc hotel of all [ __ ]
places
meeting with some of these
insurrectionists and we were talking
about this when we were preparing for
the show
about how this seems way more insidious
than just a bunch of dumb toothless
white people
showing up for a rally do you remember
what's the dude the proud boys uh
the head of the proud boys what's his
name yeah uh i didn't get his name but i
know who you're talking about they
arrested him
well the guy that got it he got in you
know he got invited
to the white house and then they tried
to play like oh he was just there for a
tour but it was like no you don't get a
last-minute tour at the white house dude
that's like dave that's like three
months in advance you have to book that
[ __ ] you can't just show up for a white
house store
you literally have to book it three
months in advance so the fact that
you're trying to tell me you were there
for a tour
have you seen have you seen though the
story uh
today and apparently it's being released
that that guy
um and i i can't remember his name i i
i know you're talking about because he
was arrested several weeks ago before
january 6 the week before and uh they
they expelled him from dc the judge says
you can't come back to dc you're not
allowed in dc
but apparently this morning what is
being reported now i i know we'll know
more about this in the coming weeks
but apparently either he was an fbi
informant or they turned him
into an fbi informant at that point um
it's very unclear at this point when
where i i can't pin down exactly from
these reports of
of what that is right but if that's the
case if he was undercover
um meaning that he was undercover for
months and months and months
uh you know maybe maybe there is more to
this story than not
and and even more to the story today
we all know that there was a police
officer killed during the insurrection
right but there was a police officer who
committed suicide days after
but apparently those reports of another
police officer committing suicide now i
don't i don't know at this point
it's very unclear if if those things go
together
or not um but it it seems
really suspicious that all these these
uh
a couple suicides happen uh police
officers
uh this guy's flipping as an informant
he may have been undercover who knows
for how long
and maybe maybe he is an undercover cop
you know i
i don't know i think a lot of those
proud boys you know they they do have
former military or law enforcement
service that's where they get a lot of
this machismo [ __ ] from
uh that makes me culture of the military
and law enforcement
um and that and that's you know that's
that's all culture
and uh that's one of the problems that
we have in some of those cultures
and and i get it that to some degree to
be
a law enforcement agent and even
you know i don't give a [ __ ] if you're
male or female you have to be able to
at least project the image of being able
to handle yourself in this situation
because if you don't
you're going to end up getting you know
i i've i've seen videos of a lot of and
that's another thing
too i i know there's you know
black people getting shot by police is
is not a good thing
okay it's not but i've seen a lot of
videos of police
just doing their jobs who have lost
their lives
just doing their jobs they weren't being
racists
they weren't weren't shooting anybody or
tasing anybody unnecessarily they were
doing their jobs and
you know i one video and i i i need to
find it because i need to post it i need
this female cop had pulled this guy over
and i mean he was bigger than she was
and his daughter is literally standing
there watching this whole event
and he just literally she's about to
arrest him and she he literally just
turns around and just
bam and just boom boom boom
his daughter is crying and he's like i
can't go back to jail baby
so now this cop is lying on the ground
by the way
eye socket shot
she's fighting for her life because this
dude don't want to go back to jail not
they just
say of course he got arrested but
it's it's it's one of those things that
we need to discuss
in depth yes i know there are a lot of
duck police out here i know that for a
fact
but yeah whether you want to hear it or
not there are cops out here who just do
their jobs
they just do their jobs man they're not
trying to be those people but at the
same time
you you know you say to those people why
don't you turn those people in
that's an easy thing to say on the
outside to see if you're one of those
police officers in case you all have
never seen the movie serpico
uh uh honest cops do not fare well
um it is it is not something that seems
to be a
mandatory trait that they are looking
for in law enforcement hey
if you you know we don't give a [ __ ] you
break a law to here or there to get the
bad guy
but you got cops out there that won't do
it they won't participate and as a
result
they don't move up in the force they
don't go anywhere they're
they're they're they're treated like a
pariah because they're the guys that you
know will then
he he might rat you out if you do
something it's like but you know that's
kind of how it should be
but it's none of those discussions again
the relationship between the police and
the public is another one of those
discussions like race
it needs to be had it's going to be an
ugly discussion
it's not going to be pretty that's
another thing and you know again
race discussion about race belief all
these discussions that nobody's
discussing anything everybody's got
great points to make
but nobody wants to shut up long enough
to hear the other person's side
to actually try to fix something see at
some point black people are going to
have to actually sit down and listen to
what white people have to say
i know that sounds really stupid i know
it sounds crazy
but you have to understand when when
you're saying
black lives matter and white folks are
basically seeing black people kill each
other
it's kind of a mix you have to
understand how confusing that is to some
people
i'm not saying it's right wrong or
indifferent i'm just saying the
discussion has to be had
and people have to shut up for five
seconds and listen to the other side
and then respond instead of listening
to answer because most people don't
listen to learn they're listening to
respond
they're just waiting their turn to say
well this is why you're wrong
instead of saying well maybe i don't
know what i'm talking about maybe i need
to take five minutes and think
but the whole relationship between the
public and the police again is one of
those things that that
is this um it's this double-edged sword
it needs to be discussed because the
police
you know people say they hate the police
i hate the police but when you need the
police
you want the police there you want the
police to show up and help you and
and and you don't care that they're the
police
but people need to understand that
that's a that's a very
people don't understand that's one of
the toughest jobs in the world
i mean it really is and again i'm not
trying to defend anything that's ever
done or any cop that's
ever done anything bad trust me on this
one but i need you to understand
something when i say this this is a hard
[ __ ] job
and i understand that the people who
took it willingly took it you knew the
job was dangerous when you took it
that's why they gave you a gun okay
but at the same time you have there's a
responsibility that comes with having
that gun and that badge
and you have to understand that okay i
hear cops say well my life was in danger
okay dude with all due respect every day
you walk out of the house with the badge
on your chest
your life is in danger because you're a
cop there's people who want to kill you
just because you're a law enforcement
agent
okay so you can't take a situation and
go
well well i felt my life was a danger
that's why i shot that guy 17 times
that's like a fireman
standing outside a burning house going
man i'm not going up in there
i i might die that's that that's
dangerous for me
my life could be in danger
there's so many aspects of things to
discuss and that's all
this was i this is the one thing i
always try to do i i yeah i give trump
supporters a hard time
i do because y'all deserve a hard time
for
four years of some serious freaking
[ __ ] i mean
you all deserve your balls busted i'm
just saying but but don't think i don't
care about you
if i if i didn't care about you i
wouldn't bust your balls
but you're going to have to make a
decision on what team you want to be on
and no i don't talk about democrat
republican
i'm talking about good versus evil you
know what i'm talking about
for four years this [ __ ] ain't been
right trump supporters you
know it if you all want this unity
that you're screaming for now your first
step is to cut donald trump loose
because that's the only thing that's
going to convince me that you're ready
for true unity because you can't you
can't bring unity and be talking about
well trump is still the greatest
president no he's not
no he's not at some point it's just
going to have to be
you know like i said i'm trying to i
could tangent for days bro
so let me so let me ask let me ask you
because i was thinking about this
i've been thinking a lot about this
unity thing and you brought up black
lives matter and
and and those sort of things and it
feels like to me
because we went through two black lives
matter movements in this country there
was one after
in my state after michael brown was was
was killed
right um and and that was a huge moment
in this country
uh barack obama was the president at
that time uh
jay nixon was the democratic governor of
missouri at that time
so there was a lot of it was a different
setup altogether right and
it seemed like at that moment um
there wasn't a lot of trust from
black people to white people regardless
if the white people were
on black lives matter side or not it
didn't seem like there was a lot of
trust there
but when this george floyd moment
happened it really felt like
that this this last when black lives
matter happened again
and this movement happened last summer
after george
floyd was obviously killed uh and
murdered
right when he was murdered on video and
i think
when when white people said you goddamn
right black lives matter
i think black people trusted that that
was
how they actually really felt and it was
the truth
and that and that was the in that and
that type of unity
is really what built around um
trying to unify against fascism and and
this there's a trust there now it seems
like
that may have not been there when when
the michael brown incident happened
well he was when he was killed and
murdered um there wasn't that trust
there yet
but through that moment and through
george floyd's moment there there's this
there's this sense of trust in this
country and there is unity
i mean let's face it there's a bunch of
bourgeois
and and hippie liberals that are
cheering on
corporations for for free market
capitalism
about tearing down these morons who want
to incite violence and perpetuate racism
in this country
so so so there are there are
natural enemies uh economic enemies and
political enemies in this country
that are unifying to say enough's enough
with this [ __ ] and these lies
and this propaganda and all this not i
mean jesus christ we have
we have fox news host crying on
television about how they lost twitter
followers
and this is the most egregious thing
that's happening in our country are you
[ __ ] serious
we are losing over four thousand people
a day because of a virus because you
it's because people can't get their
[ __ ] [ __ ] together we got
we we have cops that are murdering and
and trying to hurt black people i mean
that
is a [ __ ] thing that is happening we
have we have economic issues people
losing their jobs people not making
enough money to make ends meet
kids aren't getting the education that
they need right now because i mean
there's so many [ __ ] issues and these
people are crying about how many twitter
followers they lost
you know something i'll tell you what as
far as prosecution goes
and and i felt this way for a hot second
uh anybody at fox news
who helped perpetrate that [ __ ] you
need to be
prosecute because you are one of the
reasons this [ __ ] got as far as it did
because you helped perpetrate that
[ __ ] story about how the election
was stolen from donald trump when you
all
knew it was a damn long you knew it was
a life i think that's the thing at the
end of the day
that frustrates the [ __ ] out of me is
that you all know it's [ __ ]
and you still push it and you know these
people are going to eat it up because
that's exactly what they [ __ ] do
and now you're at this point where you
fed the monsters so much
the monster's too damn big you can't
control the [ __ ] monster
because now the monster is standing
outside going hang mike pence
what the hell well you know what you
know what's crazy is
what what gets what gets in my brain
stays there
is how one of the most prominent figures
of this thing
is grandpa farty mcsharty rudy giuliani
are you [ __ ] kidding me you people
are still believing this garbage after
it comes out of the guy
who got tricked he got tricked by
borat for [ __ ] sake this guy
this guy was caught on film thinking he
was with
someone who possibly was underage
drinking with her
goes into the bedroom he's talking
talking in his shirt come on
annie got michael you know again any guy
knows
any guy knows who is reaching down in
his pants the way that he was
is not tucking in his [ __ ] shirt i
have never laid on my back to tuck in my
shirt
ever i don't tuck my shirt into my balls
and that's not how it works the dude was
tuck if he was tucking anything he was
doing the tuck up
he was talking up the chub of the sad
part about it is rudy giuliani
used to have some degree some degree
of of respect the man was a federal
prosecutor i mean
there was a time where people believed
that he was respectable
oh my god dude but he i mean it's sad
now
the whole thing i because i even posed
the thing with the
the the black running down his face
it's just like g you're a joke now bro
you're a running [ __ ] gag now no one
ever
ever i'm never going to there's no part
of me
that's ever going to take you seriously
again rudy i don't care what podium
you're standing in front of dude
there's just this i'm never gonna take
you seriously again
you know it's like it's like ben shapiro
it's like i used to listen to ben
and then i hear ben didn't understand
that [ __ ] was supposed to be wet i'm
just
like i have not heard that and that's
that's
news to me but it that he looks like the
type of guy
he looks like the type of guy that would
believe
that the whole story is if you if you've
never heard it i don't mean to offend
anybody so
you're you're on the tony michael's
podcast we are here
to offend it's youtube [ __ ] so
yeah it's a little too late
um no um
chef wait a minute wait a minute ben
shapiro ben shapiro thank you thank you
it's a tangent thing ben shapiro was
talking about the um
the song w.a.p oh [ __ ] yeah cardi b
right he was talking about the song wet
ass [ __ ] white that's what
it stands for right apparently mr
shapiro's wife had informed him
that um if if it's wet
it's unhealthy
i'm thinking dna tests bro on all those
whatever kids you got
yeah if your wife is telling you that
it's i'm like really ben did you really
actually
that it's supposed to be no man i'm like
come on
do you real do you really think he
believes that [ __ ] okay let me put it to
you this way
all bench i know ben shapiro is a lawyer
i know benjamin is an accomplishment
musician but i don't think ben shapiro
knows
anything about being a man i'm just
saying
well he looks like the type of guy he
still sounds
like he's 16 years old well maybe maybe
maybe maybe uh now that we're talking
about ben uh
youtube will pick it up in the algorithm
and and feed it to him um
and see and see just what michael j one
black man's opinion
is on him no i would i tell you what i
would
love the opportunity
i would love to meet ben shapiro in
front of an audience i would absolutely
positively relish the chance for the
banter demolishment i'd like to give him
his shot
yeah well i i would very much because
he broke listen to me i appreciate the
you know one of the reasons i oh you
know the reason i like shapiro
was his whole you know i'm gonna bring
evidence to the table and i don't have
any problem with that i don't have a
problem with a guy
coming to the table with facts okay
you know i don't i may have not
necessarily liked how he came to the
table with it
but shapiro always came with stats
don't you think don't you think though
that that's one thing that that
uh that they keep trying to do
and it's just it's you know they're
doing it with this trial stuff
because we haven't gotten into this
trial they're doing it with this is
they're
they're they're they're they're they're
saying oh there's two
sides to every story there's two sides
that that was my but
but as i was going to say it's it's it's
the fact that
when it comes to the discussion of
certain issues
race for example it's always
okay well you know uh you know it you
know seven
black men have been shot by police well
statistically more whites get shot than
mike
it's like their response to
the emotional stress that black people
suffer through
is a statistic about how that's not
really important right well i
i mean i mean that's their mo is to
dehumanize issues
well they always do and they they have
to make sure they continue to do it
because they don't ever
want there to be a time when white
people aren't afraid of or are thinking
poorly
of black people oh you hit the [ __ ]
nail on the head
because dude they have to it's one of
the things that i've discovered this
they've been doing this [ __ ] since back
in the day
rich white men have been convincing poor
white men hey look you know you sure
you're a poor white guy but you know at
least you're not a [ __ ]
at least you're not a [ __ ] so you've
got this class of white america
who is not well educated not well to do
not well motivated and yet believe
somehow they're better but at least
they're not based on the color of their
skin
i mean i mean you know uh i grew up in
white america
uh hey so did i right i
i grew up in white america and in my
high school there was
you know one black dude and then there
was
there was a girl that was mixed race
and uh you know
that word was thrown around a lot
because you know
we didn't have to look over our shoulder
and look around to see
who was around to say that word right
and
and the word is intended to dehumanize
somebody because we we are white trash
and there is white trash and there is
you know you are scum of the earth but
at least you're not
the n-word right you're not you know so
it's all good to go and you can take
pride in that and and
when you can convince
the poorest white man that he's somehow
still better than the richest black man
he'll give you every dime he has and
that will
and that's what happens when you look at
kentucky again you look at kentucky a
state that consistently
votes republican and they are in the
shedder
well that's that's where this that's
where this take my country you're taking
you know rights away from me uh you know
they
if they feel like equality is oppression
because you're taking my privilege
because if i have to give up
something then someone must be must be
taking
something from me like you're not giving
up anything you're not giving up
anything you're just
people are getting the equal right to
that privilege people are getting the
same rights you have nobody's taking on
your ability to go to church and worship
nobody's taking away your ability to
watch monday football with a beer in
your hand
nobody's taking away your [ __ ]
collection of duck dynasty dvds
it's all golden okay again you all need
to get off this fantasy that
things are being taken away from you
because i challenge anybody to prove to
me
that anything's been taken from me prove
to me show me what's been taken from you
we're gonna lose it all we're gonna lose
at all what are you gonna lose
what are you losing that's the thing
that could because these people are
literally screaming this
we're losing it they're taking it from
us they're not taking anything from me
no one is trying to take anything of you
america is still here
america's not going anywhere and you all
need to
stop you know you i appreciate the fact
that that
that that donald trump looks like you
and you think because he looks like you
he's looking out for you
that's not like at all that it doesn't
always work like that
and donald trump proved his true colors
when he told you people to march on the
capitol i'll be right there with you
and was nowhere to be seen and ain't
been seen well
i think it'd be nice if the president
pardoned us all and the president was
like
uh right donald donald trump didn't
donald trump didn't want to talk you
know you all were his best friends
until y'all got him in some [ __ ]
trouble now all of a sudden donald trump
don't know you
right you you you you again we told you
people for four years
this man wasn't worth a damn we told you
for four years
look what he did to jeff sessions jeff
sessions was the first
person to wear the manga hat the first
person to put that maga hat on
he literally put it on literally
literally
put it on his head you see how trump did
him
you see and i'm telling you i can't
speak for anybody else but it had i been
mike pence after january 6th
you would have had to talk me down off
the 25th bro
because pence is pretty much walks
around like he's he's pretty much
norman bates okay he just walks around
dude
the man had a fly on his head and didn't
flinch
that's like i i just what i just would
have loved it
because the first time they had met when
they had like talking like days after
that [ __ ] happened
i would have loved it if pets would have
just walked in and just cold [ __ ]
just boom [ __ ]
you knew i was in there when you set
those [ __ ] up there
you [ __ ] do it you need to calm down
might not need
for nothing dude oh my god i'm gonna
you know everybody's holding secret
service is like holding ted's back
i would have loved it if you would just
throw him an ass whoop and it would have
been bro
you said those people up there without
no any idea what the [ __ ] they were
going there
i mean i mean they were they were
chanting hang mike pence
i'm this is what i'm talking about bro
oh my god i would have been bet
i would have again you would have had
look you don't want to do the 20 i'm
25th in your ass man i'm about the 25th
you
right [ __ ] down by the 25th trying to
send them
i mean hang in my pants if that right
there
didn't tell mike pence where he stood
with donald trump
well i don't know what he expected mike
pence to do mike pence was there
in a in a a a master of ceremonies
capacity mike pence had no power over
that
that ceremony at all i mean other than
opening the envelopes yeah
my attention was like and the winner is
that was my job okay
i did a video on this i did a video on
this about their [ __ ] delusion about
this
this almighty power that they thought
that they believed mike pence had
and i was like look if you really think
the vice president has this [ __ ]
power
why then in 2017 after hillary lost
why wouldn't have joe biden just said
well hillary clinton's the [ __ ]
winner [ __ ] him
you know like why wouldn't why why
wouldn't
al gore why wouldn't al gore announced
himself as the president
what the [ __ ] are you actually talking
about the vice president has this power
well that's like that's like this
delusion
that somehow have you heard this [ __ ]
that this is goes even beyond this
face-off hologram [ __ ] so
i heard the face off [ __ ] now hologram
i've heard but i heard nothing about no
john travolta
do you know the movie face off of course
of course oh my god come on that's what
a john who's best freaking movies dude
listen well it's so so
i did this i talked about this and and
that the movie is
is unbelievable and the reason why is
because they supposedly switch faces but
they keep their own bodies it's really
[ __ ] weird
but it is a good movie because it's a
90s movie
but here's the thing there are people
out there and i think this started as a
trolling thing on these uh
trump you know uh social media boards
but there was a a theory out there that
they were going to switch
donald trump and joe biden's face
that way when joe biden swears
in it's actually donald trump wearing
joe biden's face not
to not to mention the fact that you
would have to take a hundred and
sixty pound man's face and put it on a
400 pound man's
body which would be awkward but but
that that was actually a possibility so
now
now what they're saying is one of the
theories now
is i think it's march 4th is their new
date you know they keep moving
keep moving the goal post back baby
because sooner or later we're going to
get the right date
right right so so they get to march 4th
and apparently you know this is um a
theory
called uh sovereign citizens have you
heard this [ __ ] about sovereign citizens
the united states was a corporation and
somehow donald trump dissolved the
corporation
and he's going to swear in on march 4th
as the 19th president of the united
states
i'm not [ __ ] you so they they are
they are taking
they are taking all these [ __ ] wacko
looney ideas and they're mixing them all
in a soup
and they're mixing they're making a
wackadoo soup
is what they're doing and it's it's
[ __ ] bonkers but
you know what it's very entertaining and
the best part is it's going to give me
it's going to give me tick tock videos
for [ __ ] material
for uh trump supporters y'all don't
understand
you really don't you you you
all think when you come to my page and
his page that somehow
you you you're bothering us
you're feeding us you're literally
throwing
gasoline on a burning [ __ ] fire okay
so when you come with your [ __ ] know
that you're just
inspiring me to put out more of my stuff
i just want to take this opportunity to
thank you
thank you thank you trump thank you rudy
giuliani thank you marjorie taylor green
thank you lauren bobert thank you tom
and tubberville
mitch mcconnell kevin mccarthy josh
holly ted cruz
thank you thank you thank you dude
i gotta let me let me let me check this
out real quick cause i was just i
something popped up uh about ted cruz
and i just had
um ted cruz says jimmy carter
okay ted cruz says jimmy carter bill
clinton and barack obama
could be could be next in line for
impeachment
oh this is fantastic i would love that
let's do that
let's do that let's let's let's impeach
richard nixon like actually impeach him
let's actually impeach
let's do you know let's do kennedy we
can do lbj i'm all for impeaching fdr as
a matter of fact this is some of the
most
this is just sad bro it's so
sad it's just desperation
he's gonna be president i swear we just
we just
we're just gonna get the right thing
it's just like
please y'all i'm begging you so so let's
talk about the trial for a second before
we
before before we go let's talk about
this trial because let's let us talk
about it's gonna be it's gonna be big
stuff the next few weeks
as this starts to unfold um
yesterday or the day before i believe um
there was five
i believe five republican senators that
that voted
uh to say yes it is constitutional yes
uh rand paul forced this vote
on the floor to tr what he's trying to
do he's trying to get these republicans
on record i mean politically what rand
paul is trying to do
is trying to get uh republicans on
record but i think
it actually could backfire on him
because a lot of these republicans could
say
oh well it's unconstitutional but uh
according to the evidence we still have
to convict him which is a cop-out
that it's unconstitutional it's just
this way of of of
condemning you know without actually
having to deal with what he
actually [ __ ] did which was
attempted insurrection against the
united states government
i you know here's the thing that
frustrates me at the end of the day
they put charles manson in prison for
life
charles manson didn't kill a soul that's
right he incited it
he incited those deaths he didn't he
told the goat
he didn't he didn't kill anybody
and and this very idea that somehow uh
now all of a sudden after four years of
[ __ ] we should let bygones be
bygones and and we need to come together
nah bro four years of this [ __ ] you
all got a big mess to clean up
before we talk about any unity at any
time
well and they're trying to use unity to
not be held accountable
and they're spreading they're spreading
this big lie further
by by saying oh well you can't do it's
unconstitutional it's the same thing as
legal ballots you know it's the same
[ __ ] about
legal you know they everything's illegal
everything's gonna go to prison
everything is you know illegal and
itself
[ __ ] and since you since you're see
you people have already proven
you can't be trusted right you've
already proven you're willing to lie
you're a bunch of yes men who are gonna
go along with donald trump because
that's what you do i have absolutely no
reason to ever believe a republican
again
i'm here to tell you what i am a very
independent person i have voted for both
democrat
and republican i don't have any problem
saying that i did
very well under reagan i can't say
reagan was the best president i'm just
i wish i would have saved some money
spending all on booze and guitars oh yes
i did
yes i did i did yes i did uh
but it just i i i i
find it a source of amazement that that
71 million people looked at donald trump
and said
yes this is i i need more
of this it was never about his policies
it was always about the fact because one
people did the thing that people say and
we all said that they drank the kool-aid
nobody
was brainwashed nobody was hypnotized
all donald trump did was said out loud
what those people thought on a daily
[ __ ] basis
and the fact that he was the president
of the united states gave it
that just solidified it that gave it
credence oh he's
he that's why they thought he was one of
them because he has the same thought
process he thinks just like they do
that again that doesn't mean again why
you would think donald trump was one of
you
donald trump has a golden [ __ ] toilet
do you have a gold [ __ ] toilet
no you do not so he's a billionaire
but don't you think that's the gift that
he really gave us of this dumpster fire
the last four years
is that he did say the quiet part out
loud and he did make it obvious of what
i i mean he really he really showed us
the worst of us
and that and that there's 71 million of
them possibly
now i believe i believe and i've said on
this podcast before that
that part of that 71 million a big part
of that 71
71 million actually after january 6
was embarrassed and they're like no this
is this is not
this is not what i voted for oh yeah and
i'm not doing this again
so i i believe that he's lost a large a
large
uh swath of those voters and i believe
people like josh hawley ted cruz and
some of these others if they vote
if they vote to to
to not convict him i believe they're
going to play it pay a political price
just like they paid a political price
not to convict him last january
had the first impeachment have no doubt
in again
if they choose to acquit donald trump
for a second time that will literally be
the end
of the grand old party the republican
party as you know it
will cease to [ __ ] exist because
you've already got everybody up your ass
about the [ __ ]
okay about how you all are rolling now
and you think
that that i mean
do you live in this fantasy land where
there are no democratic voters
in your district where you think there's
nothing but republicans and you're going
to have you know all the republicans are
going to come out and vote for you in
2022 and 2024.
it's it's it's like you all think
that we're going to forget about january
6th
in two years in four years
bro that's not going anywhere that's not
going anywhere the republican party is
going to have to grab ahold of this
[ __ ] concept
you all better start walking on water
because that is the only way you all are
going to see any kind of solid
reelections
anywhere down the line in the future
because the united states of america has
absolutely no reason to trust you
or anything you say again you went along
with a
a real estate developer you went along
with a reality tv star who knew
absolutely nothing about what he was
doing and you
thought at no time to hold him to task
now that your political career is in
danger now you want to pretend
well we need to reign
yup four years people four years you had
four years to sit on this chump
and you let him slide on every [ __ ]
occasion now all of a sudden we need
unity no
donald trump needs to be punished and
everybody who helped him
get where he got needs to feel the same
state
i'm not saying it has to be as deep
because let's be honest we both know
donald trump probably won't see any
prison time
but we do know the irs is going to
stroke
we do know the irs is going to stroke
donald trump hard because i tell you
this one thing about the one percent
if you're in the one percent
and you [ __ ] over the 99 they don't care
but if you're in the one percent and you
attempt to [ __ ] over the one percent
the one percent will punish you [ __ ]
a right
everybody seems to have forgotten that
they put martha stewart
in jail that's right and she was pretty
white and
pretty rich so don't think that they
won't lock you down
donald because you know
just to make a point and that and that
is one black man's opinion that is one
black man
man i really appreciate you coming on
the podcast today it is
an absolute pleasure and i think i think
there's going to be plenty of
plenty of time to talk about plenty of
other subjects to come
um so i uh i i
welcome you back if we can ever chat
about other subjects
and i'm sure the trump supporters will
come up maybe maybe maybe when we start
to see some of this uh
some of these people actually uh seeing
prison sentences maybe i'll have you
back and we'll talk about those so i do
appreciate but what i want you to do
before we go is i want you to tell
people
uh because i know you do have a band and
stuff uh so i want you to give a
give some shameless plugs here where to
find you yes they like your music
let me go ahead and be shameless if you
if you dig the acoustic stuff i do
um you can find me on facebook at the
acoustic
acoustic michael j um if you
uh like pirate music i have a friend of
mine named
shay watkins we have a lovely little
pirate band called pirates creed
you can find us also on facebook also on
twitter
also on instagram if you want to check
out any of our music feel feel free to
check the any of the music sites
including spotify uh amazon
music apple all that other stuff where
they're just waiting for you
go check it out please uh if you're a
video game
if you're a huge gamer like me um
please visit me on facebook at the new
world order that's d
a n e w w u r l d
o r d e r i play on
i play on uh on xbox i play on
playstation and also on pc
so look me up i love to have more
friends because you could never have too
many because
well a boy right here yeah
god god help you if we ever get a show
together
that's right so so i want to thank you
again for coming on and
and all that stuff i'll try to get into
the description
all the links and stuff if you do if not
i'll stick it on that's right
that's right uh but definitely go follow
him on tick tock if you're not already
because uh you're gonna
you're gonna be in in and uh
well as long as he doesn't get banned
from his
his hate speech against trump supporters
you'll get some good parodies there i
that's that's probably my favorite
part about your page is the parodies i
appreciate it man
i really do and uh uh we'll talk to you
soon
and that's good keep it going and hey
[ __ ] them
[ __ ] up
so that was michael j one black man's
opinion
i am so grateful that he came on as my
first guest
we're gonna try to get more guests on
here and i i do want to tell you guys
that
this podcast is gonna be every wednesday
at three o'clock uh it looks like we're
going for an
hour now um and and there's no way that
i was gonna keep michael j
at a half an hour there's no friggin way
that that guy was gonna
was gonna not talk for at least at least
an
hour and a half i actually reigned him
in at an hour i believe so
but you're going to be able to go and
see this on a recording on youtube so go
catch that
on the channel and subscribe while
you're there because you want to catch
the future episodes because
i'm going to try to get more guests on
this show
and i want to get some tick-tockers
because that's how people kind of know
me is from tick-tock
and i think that those those guests will
uh will
will work well on the show but let me
let me let me tell you one more thing
before i go
uh we are trying to get on apple podcast
um we
are trying to get we are up on spotify
so if you just search us on spotify
let's talk the tony michaels podcast
you'll find us there
if you like to listen to podcast if not
come here and you can watch it here
but uh you know we'll see you later i
appreciate you joining us today and one
last thing
one last thing before i go [ __ ] um
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime
follow tony on social media at the tony
michaels
and until next time raise a fist and
repeat after me
[ __ ] them